the word of the day is eclipse but not
for the reasons you think I'm always
flummoxed by how one story can eclipse
another before our attention spans were
reduced to that of skittish gnats we
spent time on a story now two big ones
slip right bias both about foiled plots
one in Barcelona still killed 14 people
but the fiends intended to kill 100
times that targeting a popular tourist
attraction the Basilica of the Sagrada
família using vans packed with
explosives
they blew each other up instead in an
apartment but the survivors resorted to
killing tourists with a van another plot
involved explosives placed in a Barbie
doll and a meat grinder meant to take
down an Australian jetliner the bombs
didn't make it on the flight because the
luggage they were in was 15 pounds over
the limit that should provide you no
comfort that plot failed not because
they were foiled but because the creeps
screwed up that's pretty scary still in
our world statues are a higher priority
than a relentless plan to destroy us
said it before statues don't move
terrorists do and they won't stop until
you're eliminated the more we eclipsed
that stark truth the more we remain in
the dark our lives in the hands of
creeps who pine for the truly dark ages
yes the media says we're not supposed to
look directly at an eclipse they don't
want you look at it Barcelona or
Australian airports either alright that
is one going to you first get you out of
the way so I don't so I can stop
sweating yes um that airline plot was
foiled by a silly mistake they made
packing the suitcase I think we talked
about this this plot last week or two
weeks ago they over pack that's how they
were stopped that should scare you it
does I mean it's not only that you know
there's so many now where for example in
this Spanish situation where they blew
themselves up so if they hadn't blown
themselves up then they would have had
the gas cancer because their intent was
to do far greater damage right so you
just have to you know understand where
bomber remember the underwear bomber on
exactly 9 yeah blows up himself trying
to take down an entire plane but I do I
do have a lot of faith and trust in the
idea that our intelligence a
he's telling around we are working hard
and trying their best I don't know
again I don't want to accept this as the
new normal but I don't think that if
some guy you know out in the woods is
collecting gas containers and intends to
come in and you know blow up a movie
theater or attack it you know I don't
know how you stop all of that by the way
I I didn't appreciate your little
comment there about statues
I think statues in that context can
inspire the kind of nasty behavior that
leads people to be killed
let me when you find that let me know
Kimberly what is it about human nature
that requires like like an actual act to
take place for them to why isn't up and
instead when something gets prevented
yeah we just get on with our lives an
old adage Greg what seeing is believing
mm-hmm very good Shane twins again
trying to save time yeah no but it's
true because it's like the horror and
what happened to viciousness the
depravity that was just you know waged
against the United States and 9/11
everybody was four measures and making
sure and supporting the President to do
we needed to do for national security to
protect us to keep us safe
and sadly time passes and then it
becomes okay do we forget about this and
we're here and now we're witnessing
these things happening throughout the
world and across Europe right that
should be a wake-up enough and a
reminder enough but nevertheless it's
like unless it's something that we can
like you know have some kind of like you
know it works
tangible we can touch it or feel it or
see it it almost like doesn't exist it's
written about but almost not real
doesn't manifest enough with us you know
I just I just remembered whan you are
right there wasn't it the Confederates
are linked to explosives a guy tried to
blow up a Confederate statue and was
caught so you are right I missed that go
ahead and what about the car running
over the girl I thought wasn't about a
statue I don't yeah we don't think that
was a novel they went to shower go for
what
why were they walking around the tiki
torches oh those guys those guys I'm
saying are Nazis I don't think that was
about us - I think they've used this as
a rallying car head so as you were
reading that about the two plots mm-hmm
it made me think about you were going to
hear all this nitpicking about the
president strategy on Afghanistan where
we started 2012 campaign President Obama
said
Isis is on the run right he said Osama
bin Laden is dead
GM is alive 2013 he's reelected he says
Isis is the JV squad and you're still
talking about these plots years later
from Isis and al Qaeda I'm sorry to that
you say they took my point where's the
evening but yeah we're the JV squad and
here we are and through sheer luck
sometimes we're saving lives yeah they
are still alive and well that's that
happened on flight 93 so remember
they're supposed to be six terrorists
and Reuters only five because on that
particular flight one of them are kind
of screwed up turned away by the Customs
and Border Patrol
I'm not sure though that them I don't
know if it's the mainstream media that
is driving our distractions iops now
it's the other way around
because social media is driving media
now so the other but I think the good
news is that our government we still
have enough confidence in them right to
be doing what we need them to do to
protect us that everybody in America can
enjoy the Eclipse today and I have a
moment to enjoy that and not be
terrified I think the measure of success
it's it's shared blaming we have so we
are so easily distracted it's not just
the media we're looking for it yeah
we're looking for we can't keep we can't
keep our eyes on anything much long and
not by the way that was a good tease for
the Eclipse by the way before we go you
know I want to say that the president
said we because of our military but I
think in all fairness maybe the
intelligence agencies that well are the
ones who have stopped another 911 from
happening in this country yeah it's true